good morning
so concerning the covet 19 vaccines we
have reached an important milestone
the european union has exported so far
over 1 billion of covet 19 vaccines to
the rest of the world
vaccines from the european union have
been shipped to more than 150 countries
just to name a few to japan to turkey to
the uk to new zealand to south africa to
brazil
and important is
we delivered
around 87 million doses to the low and
middle-income countries
through covax
so we made good on our promise
we have always shared our vaccination
production and capacity fairly with the
rest of the world we've said that at
least every second doses produced in the
european union will go abroad and we
have reached that with this important
milestone of exporting 1 billion doses
of vaccines to the world
while also delivering in parallel to the
european citizens
the european union has achieved within
the european union now the goal to have
more than 75
of the adult population fully vaccinated
but remained we remained open during all
this time
we continued to export even when the
vaccines were scarce here in the
european union because we know and we
knew that we will only beat covet 19 the
pandemic if we vaccinate the whole world
therefore together with president biden
we aim for a global vaccination rate of
70
by next year
the eu us agenda for beating the global
pandemic will help to achieve that
the european union is doing expert on
top of our experts
we will donate
at least 500 million doses of vaccines
to the most vulnerable countries
but we know that other countries also
have to step up so i will work closely
with prime minister draghi and president
biden to rally g20 leaders next week at
the summit in rome
behind this very ambitious goal that's
the only way to beat the pandemic thank
you